this is the latest talk in a speaker
series held by the Yale climate energy
institute the speaker series is named
nature culture action and the concept of
the speaker series is to bring engaged
environmental scholars who are also
taking their academic work outside of
the Academy and applying it to real life
engaged issues and Benjamin cervicals an
excellent person to have exemplifying
this the speaker series will be
continuing next year in some forms so
please keep your eye out and there will
be three more speakers this semester so
a couple words about Benjamin's so vakul
he got his PhD at Virginia Tech in
science and technology studies he has
written I think 16 books or more many
articles and is certainly considered one
of the most important scholars
researching energy issues today two
books that I wanted to mention one is
his book from 2008 published here in
Connecticut called the dirty energy
dilemma what's blocking clean power in
the United States a very comprehensive
an important book for those looking for
the big picture but also the details and
one of his recent books here is
published by who is this Palgrave its
energy and ethics justice and the global
energy challenge and I think there's a
couple new ones coming out including a
book on energy security I just want to
say Benjamin cervicals been a professor
at the National University of Singapore
currently associated with Vermont law
school and is currently at Aarhus
University in Denmark where he's a
director of a Center for energy
technology if I got that right so
Benjamin please come up welcome
University in Denmark don't worry I
didn't know where it was until I moved
there the second biggest city in the
rural part of Denmark so where where
Vestas and Siemens and all these other
companies make clean energy systems and
so we've invented our own alphabet
called the or whose II and alphabet for
better or for worse you know every
University has to distinguish itself
right and so that actually says Center
for energy technology in the or who's
Ian alphabet and so I've now done my
obligatory slide for my Center and can
get to the the good stuff so I thought
today we only have an hour together so I
would briefly define clean energy
because this is still something that's
contested especially in places like
Pennsylvania where shale gas is still
considered clean even though it may not
be given that this is indeed a
university I thought I should have the
slides on research methods you can see
where I'm coming from what concepts and
assumptions underpinning my ideas about
energy then we get into the meat of the
presentation the socio technical
barriers to clean energy here that
remained to this day in the United
States some international dimensions
given that what happens here in the
United States is also happening in many
other places finally so I don't drive
you all to despair there's a section
that will talk about solutions what
policies and behavioral changes can we
all do in this room to start being more
clean with how we use energy and then a
few concluding I guess takeaway remarks
so first definitions what is clean
energy for me I think it's everything
you see in this slide this very busy
slide so you have your wind turbines
wind farms onshore and offshore on your
left that's actually wood chips being
combusted at a plant
that's to remind me to mention biomass
waste to energy landfill gas capture
then you have solar photovoltaic panels
you can also do concentrated solar power
those also falls under my definition
this is geothermal steam out west above
is of course a river so hydroelectricity
both micro and reservoir based
large-scale dams and then you have two
things that that are always included
that light bulb is to remind me to
mention energy efficiency which is not
often viewed as a supply-side solution
and there's this fierce debate about how
reliable efficiency can be given the
rebound effect things like that I happen
to think that it's probably the best
least cost solution we have before you
even get to everything to the left and
then those of you that are very geeky I
suppose may even recognize that this is
a combined heat and power plant which is
a plant that makes not just electricity
but also heat and now we even have what
are called tri generation systems that
will do heat electricity and steam or
cooled air so you can use one source of
energy to do multiple services is the
idea and to give you a really depressing
statistic as of last year the average
efficiency for a typical power plant was
36% so you take a hundred units of
energy coal oil gas you put it through
that power plant you're getting 36 units
out right so we're losing 2/3 of the
energy of our fuels every time we try to
make electricity combined heat and power
plants can get that number up to 60% so
you're doubling the efficiency of how
those work in terms of energy delivered
so that's why I treat them as part of
clean energy so it's renewables
efficiency and then what's called
distributed generation or cogeneration
combined heat and power so what is clean
energy not for this discussion I'm only
focusing on electricity got an arrow
it's somehow so I'm not gonna talk about
cellulosic ethanol corn based ethanol
sugarcane ethanol electric vehicles or
biodiesel of biofuels I would love to
talk about them but I don't have the
time then you also have these wonderful
systems which many of you can recognize
as well as a young photograph of me and
graduate school at the bottom in front
of a pile of coal in West Virginia
I do not treat petroleum as a renewable
resource although I have been at a
conference where an oil executive made
the case that oil is renewable on the
scale of you know geology it will renew
itself saying with coal and gas and
nuclear that's a nuclear reactor being
built in Korea that's a natural gas
combined cycle power plant in Thailand
that's an oil rig in Azerbaijan and this
is a big bunch of coal in West Virginia
and yes I have taken all the photos so
no copyright issues so why talk about
just electricity and clean electricity
well as of last year electricity is
still the single largest source of our
greenhouse gas emissions it's larger
than forestry it's larger than transport
larger than agriculture all those other
things right and so if you want to make
the biggest bang for the buck for the
climate its electricity first at least
in that way secondly and talk about
justice and ethics about 4.3 billion
people out of sevenish have access to
electricity networks but only about 2.1
million people have reliable access to
motorized transport so you're also
dealing with an electricity a system and
energy system that more people use
consistently and reliably the third
reason if any of you ever get into the
details of the International Energy
Agency is we owe the World Energy
Outlook you'll see all these demand
curves and these should always be
treated with caution looking into the
future but generally they will show you
electricity use will grow faster than
overall energy use why because we're
doing things like electrifying large
parts of Asia and Africa and because
we're putting electricity to more
productive uses recharging iPhones you
know electric arc furnaces neon signs
movable sidewalks right all these things
you can put electricity to do and then
finally there are efforts underway at
which I am a huge advocate of trying to
electrify transport so even though this
conversation we're about to have will
cover the electricity side if we go
where we want to go by 2030 we may have
an integrated system where electricity
is in most of our vehicles and so that's
kind of a backdoor into transport issues
and this just shows you from the EPA
it's horribly out of date I think
2006 my apologies even for the US you
can see that its electricity is a larger
source what is this Tara grams of co2
equivalent emissions than any other type
so even for this country which you would
think we have so many cars we have more
cars than licensed drivers right yet
electricity is actually still a larger
source of our emissions so that's why I
thought I'd narrow the focus there today
it's always good to talk about research
methods I'm a social scientist sometimes
that gets me applause sometimes that
gets me boos it depends I guess on the
audience which means I really like
research interviews they're open-ended
you can get really rich contextual
descriptions from participants and so
I'm presenting research today that
actually draws from two separately
funded thank you very much
funded research programs one was from
the NSF so the National Science
Foundation post 9/11 had this thing
called Epis electric research power
networks efficiency and security program
it was designed to make the grid more
secure in case there was a terrorist
attack there were 31 universities that
were doing Research Projects 30 of them
were doing the science and the
technology ours was the only one doing
the social side so we were looking at
barriers business models policy
incentives you know costs benefits that
sort of thing which was fascinating so a
lot of this research comes from that
program they paid for the interviews
they paid for the travel and all of that
and then I replicated the study when I
happen to move to Singapore to work
there with the nice Ministry of
Education academic research fund which
is kind of the same as their NSF which
is the research project that I'll talk
about solutions both of these there are
a lot of words in this slide this bullet
point describing my message each of them
has meaning but I I can explain them
later if you want basically it just
means I attempted to look at a variety
of stakeholders I did not attempt to
guide answers I did not attempt to
impose my values on subjects I did not
start with my conclusions pre-formulated
I drew them through grounded theory
right based on the data itself these may
mean something to you who are in your
methods classes or they may just sound
really boring I like this because this
method gave me
more than three thousand pages of data
of stories and narratives and
explanations and studies and all of that
to sift through in addition to the
reports and the actual articles that I
got to read so the first study the one
that's the bulk of today's presentation
was the result of I think 186 interviews
ninety three institutions 13 countries
took me three years man that was a long
time and basically I went around the
world and asked some of the smartest
people I knew if renewable energy is so
great why aren't people using it and if
there are all these barriers what can
you do to overcome them the traditional
answer of why clean energy doesn't work
is a technical answer and there was
actually a CEO who testified in front of
the House of Representatives 2006 so not
so long ago who actually said we just
can't do renewables yet the technology
isn't there it's like quote going to the
moon with 1950s technology right just
can't do it and this complements a very
long line of thoughts about why
technologies fail so the electric
vehicle from 1899 which is in the left
part of this graph failed because it's
battery didn't charge long enough
the Challenger blew up because of the
o-ring on the booster rocket the 8080
picture phone was too expensive and the
nuclear reactor Three Mile Island failed
because of some improper designs and
operating procedures right that's the
traditional answer a more sophisticated
answer says well maybe the technical
failures are only a piece of the overall
puzzle maybe the electric vehicle also
failed because there's a woman in that
photo and they became associated with
femininity
whereas auto internal combustion cars
became associated with masculinity and
ruggedness and industriousness right and
so there were gendered implications to
why that one vehicle didn't make it and
the other one did
maybe NASA was a whole organizational
mess and they were pushed for political
reasons to expedite a launch that had a
schoolteacher on it which also had
implications for the Cold War and you
know signifying that we knew we could be
competitive in space when we shouldn't
have so there were organizational
failures to complement the technical
failures maybe the picture-phone failed
not because President Kennedy was a fan
but because people didn't like the
invasion of privacy right we our we're
very you snout of these video skypes but
the picture phone people were
uncomfortable they were used to talking
on the phone and maybe picking their
nose or scratching themselves and on the
picture phone you can see it right so it
failed for issues of privacy nuclear
powers demise in the United States
probably has a lot less to do with
things like Three Mile Island and more
to do with things like this the protests
over Seabrook or shorten or all this
other nuclear plants the 86 nuclear
reactors that were never finished in
this country that sucked in 86 billion
dollars worth of investment Forbes
called this the worst business
investment of last century right so it
wasn't just the accident at Three Mile
Island there were all sorts of economic
and social factors that have led to the
decline of nuclear power in this country
so the approach the conceptual approach
that I take for my research which I love
is called the socio-technical systems
approach Thomas Hughes developed it in
this great book that I urge people to
read if they like history about how
electricity networks and I think Denmark
Germany in the u.s. took off and
basically the two key terms here are
system and momentum so by system Hughes
doesn't just mean a network of
generators and capacitators and
transformers and wires he also means the
the social system built around the
technology it's financing firms the
classes we have at universities right
the points of consumption inside our
homes this flips that we switch when we
enter a room that's all part of the
system and Hughes's point is that if you
focus on only one piece of the system
you'll ignore or miss the other elements
he focused just on cost you'll ignore
the political side you focus on the
political side you ignore the cultural
side the other thing he terms is this
thing called momentum large-scale
electricity and technological systems
have momentum right they have Milazzo
mass velocity direction that gives them
the ability to influence our decisions
right this is called soft determinism if
you want to get into the STS literature
science technology studies and so it's
not that these systems determine our
behavior but they certainly impact it
constrain our choices
constrain what's possible or feasible
which means it's a mistake if you read
David Nye who's another historian to
think about the process of how we choose
electricity as a passive process we're
not just consumers electricity and its
consumption and its use are social
decisions and choices that we make every
day and it is that amalgamation of
choices that impacts the entire network
so don't forget it's not just a
technical thing it's also a thing about
choice and about the social narratives
the social spaces in which we use and
are using right now energy what does
this mean as we go forth on my journey
to explain why clean power is not doing
as well as it could be first the system
you see isn't necessarily the one that
should have been so everything was
contingent the electricity network that
we have today was the result of a number
of it complex decisions right that at
times may not have happened the world
war two World War one both played a key
role subsidies for oil gas and coal in
the 1890s played a huge role all of
these things were the result of
negotiation and compromise right so the
idea that the system as it is today was
somehow optimally planned from the
ground up is a mistake second energy
systems are like congealed culture right
they can order society in the same way
that they actually send electrons or
order their transmission networks so in
other words values get built into the
system and we'll talk more about some of
those values centralization economies of
scale etc in a little bit
third invisibility the electric utility
system in most places is invisible if
you ask children in kindergarten to list
technology they will very rarely say
electricity they will say iPad or they
will maybe say I don't even oh the new
toys out these days I'm already out of
date you know mobile phones cutting edge
things like that the Internet at least
20 years ago sewage networks
telecommunications electricity systems
are like they are natural to us they
become naturalised there is ordinary to
us as as dirt and air and so we are
largely we think they're invisible we
only notice them when they go wrong and
that's very big
cool yer cuz it's like the degree to
which electricity has become integrated
into our lives is also the degree to
which we don't recognize it as being
integral to our lives
finally it means going back to the
slides you saw earlier contests over
failure are not always about a
technology working or not working in a
technical sense they could also be
whether it works in a political economic
or social sense and I definitely think
that's the case with clean power in the
u.s. today it also helps us classify the
way that I'll talk about the barriers to
clean tech in the next few slides it's
not just about the technology it's also
about price signals regulations and
policies consumer attitudes and yes even
things like aesthetics how they look how
they feel these all get built into the
seamless web of the socio-technical
system so the easiest barriers to
identify today to the clean energy
source as I mentioned are technical like
it or not wind and solar are
intermittent in ways that conventional
sources of energy aren't they have their
own issues with intermittency for
instance a nuclear reactor has to go
down for almost 90 days when it refueled
and sometimes you don't have enough
uranium to power the fuel rods which
means you have shortages right so there
are issues there but for the most part
you don't necessarily have these weird
load profiles like here I'm showing
offshore wind by the way because that's
actually the largest source of renewable
energy near the East Coast it's not
hydro it's not onshore wind it's
actually offshore wind and you can see
here the profiles of wind speeds for I
think what is this you know three months
or so in 1999 it's very variable and
this leads this is what a vice president
of exelon exelon is the biggest utility
in this country they are in Illinois
they have a lot of nuclear plants they
actually said you need six megawatts of
wind they get something like one
megawatt of fossil field because you
can't always be guaranteed the argument
runs that the wind will be blowing when
you need it and it gets even worse when
you see things like Germany right
because Germany's far ahead of the US
this shows you the average generation of
wind electricity the whole year 2012 and
you can see such great variability from
0.007 terawatt-hours up to zero point
5:3 terawatt-hours that is some
significant variability so these systems
are hard to integrate into a system
where supply and demand have to match
each other instantaneously it also means
you're gonna have to build a lot of
transmission networks to go where these
resources are and in the case of the
United States
NREL the National Renewable Energy Lab
2012 put out this report that found we
have to invest something like a trillion
dollars or more in high-voltage
transmission networks to harness just
wind energy let alone the other types
solar geothermal and hydro and you have
the same intermittency problems for
these other systems like
hydroelectricity and inconsistent
snowfall and precipitation like solar
right which differs from day and night
also differs from season to season right
there's a lot less Sun out now than
there will be over the summer or biomass
which has different growth cycles and
lower energy densities I was amazed this
is from last week from NOAA national not
the preacher to God but the National
Oceanic Atmospheric Administration and
it shows you the difference in snowpack
for California over I believe the past
five years so this is very recent and
you could you would have seen the snow
go all the way to the left California
intimately depends on hydroelectricity
imports from the Pacific Northwest that
depend on snowpack melt this is what do
you think's gonna happen in the next
five years right when this snow melt is
no longer there or at least has altered
in its timing or its flow or at
seasonality that's just one small way in
which even climate change is ironically
threatening resource availability of the
technologies we need to mitigate climate
change so you have these technical
barriers and some countries consumer I
can overcome them like Denmark and
others like the United States are still
trying to figure it out but that's not
it you also have these economic barriers
and so you have these fall into a
variety of different ways for one is
information failure people don't know
about it or if they do they know only
bad things right bad news travels more
than good news and so if you ask none on
a ten people about wind farms they might
tell you oh Cape Cod its disaster or I
saw that one catch fire they don't hear
that the positive news
you can also see that a lot of companies
and homeowners want returns on
investment that are much quicker they
want to make their money back in a year
right or two years rather than five
years or ten years you have split
incentives called the principal agent
problem in economics how many people
here rent their apartment okay
would any of you ever invest in better
energy-efficient equipment like windows
or a roof it may be some of you
exceptional ones would right but the
idea is you wouldn't because you don't
own the property that's a split
incentive these types of split
incentives impact the ability that we
can implement energy efficiency and
renewables as if that wasn't enough you
have predatory market power and this
just shows you an example of back in the
day there used to be interconnection
charges if you wanted to interconnect a
solar system on your house you'd have to
pay the transmission operator a bunch of
money or get insurance or bonds and
other types of protection and then
finally you have incomplete prices the
price that we've see for energy on our
bills is not the full price right it
doesn't include climate change doesn't
include pollution doesn't include water
use all these other things that someone
pays somewhere just not on your bill and
then I suppose finally behind all of
this
is this idea that not everyone wants to
become a utility right not everyone
wants to start making their own energy
at home as one of the people I spoke
with for my project said you know the
McNugget maker wants to make McNuggets
the mall manager wants to manage a mall
then none of them want to actually start
becoming concerned about efficiency and
electricity supply and interconnection
leave us alone
it's hard enough doing what we do now
without this added extra task part of
this is also the way that the system has
been built over the past 100 years this
kind of centralized model that sends
electricity in one way right from supply
to consumption and unfortunately the new
model right of decentralized supply and
reactive consumer patterns that send
energy the other way when it's needed
contravenes them in many many
fundamental ways and when you talk to
utility executives about some of the
flaws with that centralized model
they'll point to this that centralized
model has been incredibly successful
at delivery and electricity one of the
modern marvels of mankind humankind's
for almost a century
it is not easy making electricity and
you can see here its price if you adjust
for inflation in 1882 was almost five
dollars and fifty cents a kilowatt hour
right whereas its price in the 70s was
pretty much around the residential price
about eight cents and today I think it's
around twelve cents right so by and
large these guys and girls at the
utilities will say we did it we
delivered this precious commodity to you
at a far cheaper price consistently and
reliably so in other words the
centralized model worked and then you
have issues of market predatory
practices this is from a study that I
think it was Sandia National Labs and
NREL did together a few years ago
looking at the barriers to small-scale
energy supply and this you can see at
the bottom you can see how some of these
predatory barriers you had this one poor
farmer I think in Idaho or Iowa had to
wait a hundred and ninety six months you
know that's like longer than some of my
kids have been alive 196 months before
they could get approval for their
interconnection and this was all
predatory right this this wasn't
legitimate interconnection issues and
you can see all the other states on that
list Texas California Illinois
Pennsylvania Montana you can also see
here how much these types of companies
will actually surcharge you that is
beyond the amount that they should with
this poor farmer in Kansas trying to do
a natural gas system had to pay seven
million dollars in surcharges you know
and you look at there are three hundred
dollars which isn't so bad I suppose for
a small-scale wind farm or wind turbine
on a house right so these types of
predatory barriers it's not a market
that is easy to enter an exit from there
all these types of practices that can
inhibit innovation as if that wasn't
enough technical barriers the economic
barriers you have political barriers one
of these relates to expectation and hope
in the 1970s people thought that solar
energy was going to supply twenty
percent of our power by the year 2000
and rail used to be called serda the
our energy Research Institute or
authority I think President Jimmy Carter
who's pictured here put solar panels on
the White House which were later removed
by Ronald Reagan I believe his second
week in office like one of the first
things he did was take them down right
so that really signifies the change
between administrations and it can be
just as pronounced looking all the way
back right Obama Bush Clinton etc and
the different policies we've had they've
been incredibly inconsistent this shows
you the production tax credit for wind
energy in the US and I could have drawn
it out all the way to 2012 because it's
expired a few other times and you can
see the direct impact the years that
that credit has expired and actual
investments in cumulative capacity for
wind energy and you also want to talk
about comparability between classes the
tax credit for nuclear energy is for 30
years so why is it that wind is expiring
every two to three years right it's
inconsistent it's variable you that have
varying standards within the States now
in a well-intentioned move to respond to
lack of federal action we're at 33
states now have renewable portfolio
standards I think four states are
discussing feed-in tariffs like 32
states have net metering right but the
definitions vary California's is 30% by
2020 2015 mains is 10% by 2005 in
Pennsylvania coal gasification is
Canada's renewable in Hawaii it isn't in
Hawaii energy efficiency counts in Maine
large hydro does but it doesn't count in
Minnesota right so it's it's a mess
trying to get to coordinate renewable
energy credits and consistent policies
across all these different standards the
analogy that I once used is it be like
every time you cross state lines in your
car you have to then read you the tires
the color of your car the windshield and
everything else as you go from state to
state that's how the fragmented the
market still is in many cases for
national renewable electricity policies
then you also have this curious thing
that we don't spend a lot of money
public or private on energy research you
think we would given that it's such an
integral part of our economy given that
we kind of started the whole industry
right Thomas Edison the
you can see on the left public energy
our D and D spending we're even behind
China which is obviously also not known
as being cutting-edge in energy research
and you can see on the right how little
we involve ourselves in energy compared
to other things like health or defense
defense would be an even bigger bar on
that list alright I have to ask other
any young children in the room okay good
because the next slide I'm about to show
you is a little violent it's what
happens when Santa Claus decided to run
through a wind farm and and and this is
here not just to get a chuckle or
perhaps a tear it's also to remind you
that even these clean energy systems
have their own sets of externalities and
that means they do engender political
opposition there are people who hate
wind energy there are people who hate
solar energy there are people who see
this this was sent to me by someone to
say could this really happen and I
didn't know how to answer that I didn't
know how to say what if hypothetically I
suppose Santa Claus could you know I
don't think that have a wind farm though
in the South Pole but yeah you never
know but there's also that reminder that
each of these energy systems has their
own political economy and that political
economy can be very complicated even
within the industry the solar people
will point to the wind people and
they'll attack each other or even within
the solar industry the PV people and the
CSP people you know will attack each
other and so there's all of that in
fighting going on let me get to this set
of barriers which I find the most
interesting and I suspect Chris might as
well since he's studying anthropology
the behavioral barriers the barriers
that we play a more active part in so
one is complete apathy misunderstanding
actually it's higher 88% of Americans
will fail their basic energy literacy
tests that the National the Neath
National energy education training
foundation did a few years ago they also
thought that the ocean was the largest
source of freshwater by the way so we
clearly have a lot of educating to do on
environmental issues I was also a good
of story and called Marvin malossi who's
written a book called energy and
abundance and he makes the argument that
if you want to talk about our real
problem as we've been conditioned to
view energy is always abundant
right we've been spoiled so to speak
we've had three centuries of practically
limitless growth and in terms of energy
and resources and all of that and so
we've come to expect and feel entitled
to abundance and we aren't good as a
society at dealing with languages of
limits right and constraints that's not
it's not American it's not freedom right
and so many of times we we take threats
to abundance as personal threats on our
lifestyles and then you have
psychological resistance many people
don't like being told what to do there
was a famous example of an experiment in
the in the US Army where they were
trying to improve fuel economy for cars
and this would probably be annoying they
they made it so you couldn't press the
pedal that fast right so if you slammed
on the pedal the car still wouldn't move
that fast right and so of course people
hated it yes it was more efficient but
they wanted to control over their
acceleration so when actually in about a
quarter of the cases even though they
got disciplined for it the soldiers in
the experiment removed the devices I
thought I'd get rid of this crap and
that's just one idea about how even just
issues of control personal control over
the system can lead to resistance or not
and then you have manufactured
discontent I was reading a study out
last weeks I mean like a billion dollars
Union of Concerned Scientists claimed
have been put into anti climate science
recently the Koch brothers Koch brothers
however you say their name funding that
type of science to this day which then
leads to things like Fox News telling us
that climate change is a hoax and all of
that or driving in West Virginia and
seeing these types of ads you know coal
keeps the lights on or the fact that 69%
of people in the US you owned a
flex-fuel vehicle these are vehicles
that can run on ethanol or gasoline
didn't know they had one they were
unaware or the fact that many of us when
were deciding what to buy in terms of
toys and we have to use one that uses
batteries or one that plugs in we'll
choose the one with batteries even
though it's a thousand times more
expensive to use the one with batteries
right all sorts of weird things with
energy part of the reason is because
when it when it's inside your
electricity socket clean energy looks
the same as dirty energy right if
they're all electrons in a way the other
part is it's really hard to see energy
saved right show me energy efficiency in
your hand well no it's the energy that
was never
there was never used in the first place
so even calculating your savings
requires a calculator and a baseline and
a discount rate and all these other
things right so it's hard when energy
savings are invisible
which means when it comes down to it you
ask people if they'd rather put $20,000
on their house into a solar panel or
into granite countertops
ninety-five percent say the granite
countertops right even though the
granite countertops aren't going to
return anything you know
then we're shown on investment for
granite whereas the solar panel could
actually cut your bill and do a bunch of
other things so these are all examples
of where culture and behavior and
routines and values and attitudes matter
and then you get into this stuff the
manufactured discontent right this ad
near Chicago a few years ago obviously
because the Unabomber believes in global
warming it must be false right as the
top ad you know or this was in
Pennsylvania I think last year I took it
coal increasingly green it's the same
coal they've had for 50 years I have no
idea how it's increasingly green but
it's always red white and blue you know
whatever that means this example is kind
of depressing getting a little bit
beyond electricity just to make my point
anyone know what this top photo is it's
a National Wildlife Refuge in the US
probably one you've never been to it's
in Alaska and more Arctic National
Wildlife Refuge there was this big
debate George Bush administration
2002-2003 about opening it up for oil
development now the USGS has done all
the assessments about how much oil might
be there and there's a lot of different
assumptions but basically they come up
with a number and what's fascinating is
Americans could actually save more oil
than lies within the entire Arctic
National Wildlife Refuge if they just
learn to idle their vehicles properly
right this means you don't have to turn
your car on for 30 minutes to get it
warmed up it means you can turn it off
when you're at a stoplight
you know this is from Michael Vandenberg
who did a study looking at driving
behavior and found that most Americans
have no idea how to drive their car
properly from a fuel saving standpoint
and this isn't you have to go 55 miles
an hour right this is more don't idle
and properly inflate your tires right
doing things like that
entirely obviate the need for us to open
up entire oil fields if just we changed
our behavior and then you have these ad
campaigns that are intentionally false
nuclear energy institute talking about
how its carbon free when it's not you
have life cycle emissions at uranium
mines Mills enrichment facilities spent
fuel repositories decommissioning land
remediation transport of fuel all of
that right it's not missions free
neither is wind and solar you have BP
running ads that there's energy security
and energy diversity the same year they
closed down their renewable energy
division and chose not to diversify
right so you have these kind of weird
moments of complete contradiction in
advertisements and image and then what
actual company practices are or I'm an
energy voter vote for energy security
what does that mean if you click on it
it means Keystone XL pipeline obviously
that's the only type of energy security
that matters and so you have the this
entire industry that funds
misinformation this one still annoys me
anyone from Kansas the governor there
who's now a head of DHS he was
responsible for the whole Obamacare
failure but governor there decided to
phase out coal plants there was an ad
campaign run by Peabody Coal but rather
than call themselves Peabody Coal they
called themselves Kansans for affordable
energy and they ran this ad on the left
why are these men smiling because this
recent decision will now mean we have to
import more natural gas from these
countries what's wrong with this ad
apart from the fact that it was so
successful that McCain picked it up in
his campaign it was false Kansas imports
zero natural gas from any of those three
countries and in fact the natural gas
would have come from Pennsylvania had
they actually replaced Coal Fired plants
with gas plants right so again it's a
completely false ad with the group a
fake group formed to look like
grassroots community activism when it
was really just the industry
masquerading and this is just another
raw scalp span doing work on anti
climate science and the way that
ExxonMobil is also funneled you know
hundreds of millions of dollars into
these scientists to then say that
climate change isn't real
which is why in surveys America is still
divided if you look at some of the
recent Gallup polls Pew Center polls 50
percent still don't believe climate
change
happening you know in some parts of the
country especially the south and that's
how what we're going through in the
United States
I guess tragically is not an anomaly so
this was from a survey that looked at
developing countries you'd think that
have a whole other set of issues no you
can see the same sorts of things lack of
information barriers to entry lack of
equipment investment bias predatory
practices even in places like the
Philippines I was privileged to help the
UN do this report on 18 countries in the
Asia Pacific who are trying to do this
thing called sustainable energy for all
se4all which is to double the amount of
renewable energy to double the amount of
energy efficiency improvements and to
provide universal energy access and here
we found the same types of barriers
technical barriers like difficulty in
equipment economic barriers like low
tariffs political barriers like lack of
policy social and cultural barriers like
complete misunderstanding about our
solar energy works and you can see here
how the single most important barrier
affecting 15 of those countries was poor
equipment or you can see here how broken
down by country some of the worst
countries were like Mongolia and Nepal
which had the most types of barriers and
so the idea is what we're struggling
with here we aren't alone and then you
have these types of things at the
international stage where we get into
trade wars so we have a currently we
have an import duty on Chinese solar
panels because they're too cheap so
we've argued that they're actually
trying to dump their technologies below
price and so you can see all these
things that add to the cost look at the
20% tariff on solar panels and Russia
when a wonder Solar can't compete right
in southern parts of Russia that have
lots of sunlight or a wind turbine
Mexico and China at 8% and the problem
with these types of tariffs is they're
kind of like subsidies once someone does
one then someone has to retaliate and so
it's this whole kind of genie out of the
bottle kind of predatory international
barriers that become created and I threw
I had to throw this in there I know it
has nothing to do with the US but it
also speaks to how we create cultures
around different energy systems
anyone know what language this is
fantastic
can you read it neither can i but I've
been told it's a children's coloring
book for a spent nuclear fuel repository
and so what you see down here is where
they'll put the spent nuclear waste and
you can actually open up the book and
it's a coloring book they can color in
the waste canisters they can color in
the happy people floating around right
and this is because in Korea nuclear
power is seen as one of the vital
technologies of national competitiveness
and so from a very young age children in
school are taught to view it in a
certain way right and so you have then
have a very pro nuclear culture in
places like Korea what this means is
when you take all of these different
barriers trade barriers cultural
barriers political barriers economic
barriers you kind of you create lock-in
right to our conventional energy system
right the barriers perpetuate themselves
right it shapes path dependency so that
it's very difficult to challenge the the
entire system so what do we do well
we've this really pernicious set of
barriers that have existed for almost a
century renewables to this day are still
generating non-hydro renewables less
than 2.8 percent I think of our national
electricity on an on an annual basis
might be close to 3 percent if you start
to account for some of the newest wind
farms so what policy changes can we do I
took this photograph in Australia when I
was at a conference and I think the guys
were uncomfortable being photographed
but this was in a mall I was so shocked
you know 10 years ago to land and I was
looking for a Starbucks and I walk it in
there selling solar panels at the mall
and I was like you know from Ohio I
never once saw anything sold in a mall
that was a solar panel or a wind farm
right and so Australia is just one
example of countries that have started
to implement many different policies to
promote renewables now this is from the
IPCC Intergovernmental Panel and climate
change where they surveyed global
actions to mitigate emissions to reduce
greenhouse gases and you can see what
they're telling you here is I like the
political posturing one you have
different objectives and then you have
different tools that match each
objective now this is here to remind us
that some people get really diehard
about a certain policy
I love a feed-in tariff I love an RPS
and they forget that it's about what
those policies are supposed to do
instead and some of them are about
lowering prices some are about
mitigating emissions some are about
political posturing etc but if you
divide them by type there are I think
more than 90 different policy tools that
exist today if you are a regulator or a
policy maker or an alderman or older
woman 90 tools this is just some of them
and this is more of them and this shows
you how they break down across the world
if you take what's called ren21 as their
global status update these types of
policies are in a hundred and fifty
countries right so I mean like 52
countries have feed-in tariffs 65
countries have RPS is many of them have
tax credits and it goes on and on and on
and on you have all these really
aggressive EU targets for energy as well
right 50 percent for Sweden 20 percent
for the EU as a whole 45 percent for
Austria so in this sea of different
policies where you have more than 90
which ones work the best and that was
what our second study did the one that
was funded by the Ministry of Education
and we found we interviewed almost 200
experts again from a variety different
places
oil companies gas companies electricity
companies consumer groups vice
presidents and CEOs as well as actual
researchers and professors so it was a
very nice sample representative mixed
sample of perspectives and what was so
shocking to me was despite that
diversity of backgrounds the diversity
of age the diversity of gender one
hundred and eighty respondents almost a
hundred and thirty I think said the same
thing they said remove subsidies should
be the first thing you do the second
thing you do should be changing our
prices the third thing that we should do
is a feed-in tariff and the fourth thing
we should do is fund energy efficiency
dsm-v means demand-side management and
I'll talk about each of those four
things in a second first though I just
wanted to kind of chuckle and say that
there were two respondents one from Iran
who said we should have an energy police
force who goes around and arrests people
who don't invest in clean energy so that
was not a more favored policy mechanism
let me assure you I thank you for
laughing so remove subsidies why is this
the tool that almost all these experts
suggested was the single most effective
thing we can do well I was amazed by
these numbers this is for the u.s.
looking for 50 years of subsidies for
every dollar we've spent on efficiency
we spent $35 on supply-side and so
there's a huge mismatch between saving
energy and our industries and our homes
and supplying energy from our refineries
and our power plants the GAO reported
from 2000 to 2007 nuclear power received
half of all subsidies among rich
countries fossil fuels 27% renewables
just 12% and that includes biofuels so
if you cheese out electricity it's like
6% or 5%
I always like this comparison as well
the single subsidy for nuclear power
under the price-anderson Act which
limits liability for a nuclear accident
which enables them to get insurance
things like that the value of that
subsidy is worth more than all energy
R&D expenditures for renewables across
the world so one small subsidy small
subsidy in the u.s. is greater in value
than what every country is put into
renewables for giving you that's just
one example for how I guess aggressive
these subsidies can shape market
decisions and this is a good example too
if you actually put in the amount of
subsidies for a system and compare it to
what that system produced I guess this
is like subsidy cost-effectiveness you
can see for nuclear power it works out
to be 15 dollars a kilowatt hour
Douglas koplow has done a study looking
at subsidies for nuclear in the US and
has determined they resulted in a net
loss it would have been cheaper if we
gave the electricity for free and never
developed nuclear at all if you account
for all of the subsidies we've needed to
support that system and you can see wind
and solar do quite well when you use a
similar metric and you look at the same
15 years of their development and you
can just see down here 50 years of US
energy subsidies almost two-thirds have
gone to nuclear power and the trend
globally even to this day at least as of
2010 is correct renewables are
appropriately in green and you can see
that the only thing
that it's actually smaller than them is
the category other in terms of global
subsidies among the 28 members of the
OECD organization of Economic
Cooperation and Development the wealthy
countries so we still subsidize oil and
gas and nuclear and you can also see
this in indirect ways this was done by
the UNF Triple C the framework for the
conventional climate change you can see
here is how much a cost should've diesel
or gasoline should be so everything
below this line is somehow subsidized
and here is the price of what a barrel
of crude oil is so everything below the
red line is like a really serious
subsidy because they're basically giving
you a refined product less than the cost
of the input and in places like
Venezuela 3 cents per liter of gasoline
right so you can and these are countries
that don't have the largest economies
and so they eat the subsidies eat large
amounts of government revenue and cause
excess consumption Venezuela has three
times the regional average of gasoline
consumption and that is directly related
in part because they subsidize their
prices so significantly this is another
nice way of indirectly trying to measure
how much subsidies exist the IMF
International Monetary Fund has a report
that came out two months ago that
estimated that energy subsidies last
year one point nine trillion with the T
think what you could do you know that's
almost like Yale's budget one point nine
trillion dollars it's a lot of money all
right second thing we could do so the
first is get rid of subsidies period
make it an even game and renewables and
clean sources should do quite well price
signals get more aligned we minimize
excess consumption etc second thing that
our experts said is we should change the
way that we have price electricity in
three ways get rid of rate caps so there
are some places like in California where
the price of electricity is not allowed
to rise now the idea is it should so you
can expose consumers to the volatility
they'll make more judicious choices
about their energy instead this is the
California electricity crisis when this
hit SD any San Diego Gas and Electric
and PG&E sorry could not sell
electricity for more than
five cents per kilowatt-hour or $50 a
megawatt-hour
yet look how much they had to pay for it
so they quickly in these later months
went into massive debt all because
electricity wasn't priced so that its
cost was fully passed to consumers a
second way is to get rid of these sorry
that got cut off
eliminate declining block rate pricing
in many places of this country
electricity is priced the more you buy
the cheaper it is buy in bulk get a
discount like Walmart right you go and
buy twenty things and it's cheaper than
if you bought it somewhere else and so
here you can actually see how Con Ed
used to structure their rates I think
they still do it similarly in the 1970s
and what you'll find is that some
companies who are like right around here
will jump into a higher class of
consumption to get the lower price which
makes sense
however if electricity is a scarce
commodity you can actually do the
inverse you could have a sending block
rate pricing and there are some
utilities now in Arizona and California
that do this and they immediately cut
demand by 20% among industrial users
because they start to shut off equipment
now that didn't have to run they do
energy audits they do all sorts of
things so this is something that it
doesn't even cost any money you just
change the way the tariffs work and you
immediately cut consumption they do this
in Denmark and Malaysia I've seen
electricity bills
even for households so for the first
hundred kilowatt hours it's this rate
then it jumps to a higher rate for the
next 200 then it jumps for a higher rate
etc and you can bet that people start to
save electricity when they see how much
it costs in the higher classes
the third thing people have talked about
in terms of prices is price time of use
all of you receive electricity bills
I would imagine I would guess I put my
foot in my mouth if you have smart
meters it's probably better but where I
live in in Denmark I get my electricity
bill once every three months and when I
lived in Vermont I got it once a month I
would guess most of you were getting
bills like that so they don't tell you
how much electricity cost on Sunday at
midnight versus Monday morning at 3 p.m.
yet supply and electricity at the peak
in the middle of the week on a really
hot summer day is fundamentally
different different technologies
different fuel cycles different costs
then
supplying it at 1:00 a.m. on a Sunday
morning it's like the difference we
eating steak and McDonald's
Alfred Caan once said and the problem
with pricing it this way is you can't
tell what you used so be like you went
to the grocery store and it said you
bought 56 food units right you couldn't
see how much the ice cream cost couldn't
see how much the filet mignon cost or
the ramen noodles right so you have no
way to differentiate the product so
time-of-use pricing real time pricing is
the idea hourly every half hour every
day show consumers how much they're
using and what the price is and what's
fascinating is peak supply during the
the week of a week of a year where
electric utility is supplying the most
electricity they need basically
providing electricity for less than 1%
of the time during that peak week
accounts for 30% of the costs the whole
year right so the systems are built
because you have to match supply and
demand instantaneously an incredibly
complicated ways so cutting peak demand
has multiple effects every kilowatt hour
of peak demand you cut can sometimes
displace 3 to 4 kilowatts of capacity in
certain markets right so it's a great
way pricing electricity this way the
argument runs to get people to be more
aware about peak demand and then finally
the fourth thing wouldn't be nice
include externalities in the price of
energy and this diagram shows you just
the externalities with coal I could show
you similar ones for uranium or natural
gas or crude oil and what I like about
the diagram is it first of all shows you
the multiple dispersion pathways land
air water etc and also shows you all the
different life cycle stages from the
mine to the storage to the
transportation to the preparation to the
combustion to the waste disposal and any
one of these systems can cause massive
damage in Kingston Tennessee three years
ago there was a billion-dollar fly ash
spill at one power plant the power plant
didn't even cost a billion dollars to
build I think yet caused more damage
when just one of these systems failed
right and the problem with these
externalities is we're already paying
for them we're just not paying for them
on our bills we're paying for them with
increased hospital admissions higher
insurance rates
you know increased sickness degraded
landscapes
less resilient ecosystems you know on
and on and on so society pays it's just
not reflected in the price I'll speed
this up the the final two things that
our respondents said pass a feed-in
tariffs a feed-in tariff and a renewable
portfolio standard are very similar the
RPS will give you a certain percentage
by a certain time but you don't know the
price the feed-in tariff will give you a
price but you don't know how much you're
gonna get it's up to the market to
decide and there's been a lot of
evidence talks about how a feed-in
tariff is a better mechanism because
it's more stable and it's been very
successful in Germany I won't even
bother with this if you want to design a
feed-in tariff here's the way to do it
and this just shows you last year for
the 50-plus countries that had feed-in
tariffs what they were so the idea is
the median I think for a solar PV system
is fifty point three cents so the idea
is if you have a solar house you get 50
cents per kilowatt hour but if you put
wind on your house you only get what 17
cents or 12 cents so you have different
tariffs set to different technologies
based on their level i's cost of
production and what's amazing is they've
found now in all of the main countries
like Spain and Germany that have passed
feed-in tariffs for some time you have
what they've called the merit order
effect I don't know why they call it
that basically it means you spend three
building euros on the tariff to get
almost three times as much benefits
social benefits through displaced
externalities right so in Germany in
2006 I think this was they spent three
and a half 3.3 billion euros on the
tariff but they actually saved five
billion in better pricing three billion
in external costs and one billion in
avoided energy imports now the opponents
of a feed-in tariff will only focus on
the left they'll say but it costs 3.3
billion and by the way last year
Germany's feed-in tariff has gotten much
more penetrated I think it was twenty
two billion in tariffs but it saved
almost eighty billion in terms of these
other things right so the unfortunately
you have to pay but you pay to actually
save more down the road and the same
thing happened in Spain where they're
feed-in tariffs cost them about a
billion euros they've already saved 1.6
billion based on only reduced whole
civil
of electricity prices it's not even
talking climate or carbon or jobs right
just one aspect of how these systems can
pay for themselves in ways we didn't
even think was possible the last thing
is don't forget about energy efficiency
I could show you this similar graph for
the u.s. this graph blows my mind on the
bottom this actually includes the US and
ten other countries like Germany and
France in the UK and then what is this
exajoules so this is global energy
I think either supply is here and all
the energy we've saved from energy
efficiency improvements appliance
standards fuel economy standards energy
audits industrial retrofits all of those
good things are there and you can see
that if you treat it as a source of
supply the amount of energy we've saved
with those tools is greater than any
other source of supply today greater
than the oil or the natural gas or
electricity which includes nuclear and
hydro so the resource the potential for
efficiency which is cumulative right
what you saved today you passes on you
know going forward can be tremendous and
even in the US where we've had
aggressive investments in efficiency
I've seen studies from the National
Academies that still say we have 30 to
40% more than we can save
cost-effectively which is why if you all
have seen these before these great
mckinsey cost curves they're kind of
complicated to read basically the size
of the bar is how many tons you can save
and this way is the cost so the idea is
you start at the left and move to the
right the option on the far left is the
cheapest lighting you get rid of
incandescent bulbs then do commercial
retrofits and everything that has a bar
going down is cost-effective it will
save you carbon and make you money and
the idea is because many of these things
to the right cost money you use the
savings from these ones here and put
them in to pay for the ones there in any
type of climate strategy so it's a nice
kind of way of ranking and rating
different options although it has been
criticized of course this shows you the
one for the US this shows you one for
India where it turns out electric
two-wheelers and better agricultural
pumps are kind of the lowest hanging
fruit
for efficiency investments and what's
interesting is I've seen these cost
curves now for about 20 countries and
efficiency for some reason is always in
the far left these types of efficiency
things it's the best cheapest fastest
quickest way to save carbon and make
money before you move to things like
geothermal and nuclear power or
concentrated solar power so that's
partially why I'm such a big advocate of
energy efficiency all right to conclude
first I just gave you a whole bunch of
probably boring slides on policy but the
first half of the discussion was more on
politics and and the two have to find a
way of being blended together right I
mean you can have an economist come here
and tell you the ten policies that you
should be implementing but if you can't
get them implemented can't build
coalitions of support social movements
convince regulators then it won't matter
right and our research has suggested
that consensus in energy issues is
impossible I forget his name now L David
Freeman who had had led a very big
research project in the 70s once tried
to compare getting consensus on energy
issues as an academic mud-wrestle right
and this was among professors not like
oil executives etc amory lovins has
called it it's like herding wet cats
it's very hard because we all have
different political interests built into
the system and then you have this issue
of momentum so for me this question
isn't just one of finding the right
policies it's also creating the
political spaces and conditions where we
can actually make reform possible
secondly the first half of my
presentation with all of those barriers
political social economic etc implies
that we can take these beautiful maps
and reject them and you will see these
maps for all sorts of energy sources
shale gas uranium thorium wind solar
hydro and it looks great look at all of
that red right and purple in the Great
Plains this has been called the Saudi
Arabia of wind right we're blessed with
onshore in these Midwestern states and
you can calculate out you all may be
seen these these numbers or something
like in one hour we have
our solar energy that comes into the
planet then will put to use for like
three months or something and our global
economy right so all of those technical
potential estimates are interesting and
they tell us where the resources lie but
the achievable potential the social
potential is this very very small sliver
of that so these things always have to
be caveated
and contextualized third because the
system's approach socio technical
systems approach tells you that it's a
variety of barriers you have to have a
variety of policies at the same time you
have to do them synergistically at once
right rather than incrementally this
policy or that policy and California is
a good example here this is one of the
most recent projections from the
California ISO which shows their fuel
mix past 2020 so there are a lot of
uncertainties there of course but you
can see look at the increase in solar in
wind and hydro and even gas and look at
the slight increases in nuclear and look
at the complete phase-out of coal and
they're not predicting new policies
needed to achieve that they're saying
this is what business as usual will get
us given we've already done so how did
California get there well they did all
of these things at once they had
time-of-use pricing better transparency
a really aggressive renewable portfolio
standard good definitions focused on
consumer behavior and all sorts of other
things that made it a synergetic
approach and Denmark has done the same
thing
Denmark has had a carbon tax a feed-in
tariffs tax credits long term Power
Purchase Agreements accelerated
depreciation of energy projects
accelerated permitting you know a whole
bunch of things as well energy
efficiency savings trusts that they did
to get on their path and Germany is the
same way right so this idea that we can
just do one policy a feed-in tariff or a
tax credit and voila it's solved our
problem doesn't recognize that if the
barriers are political social and
economic the solutions and policies have
to be social political economic at the
same time for parity and this tends to
be the case this is from a book I wrote
a few years ago for MIT press where we
looked at 2000 climate friendly
technologies categorized by the
Department of Energy
and then we thought these things are
great they could do so much cutting
carbon and then we started to look at
their barriers and you can see what a
mess right I mean energy and use and
infrastructure systems at the top had
all of these even just financial
barriers let alone other things like
intellectual property barriers or lack
of information or uncertainty over
policies et cetera so you know the idea
is if this is the mess of barriers you
have to have a collage of policies to
overcome the barriers final conclusion I
think if you think the findings in this
talk are valid that a lot of the
barriers aren't just technical their
political and their social and their
economic and their cultural and if it's
about politics as well as policy we have
to fundamentally change the way we think
of energy Rd nine out of every ten
dollars of R&D in this country for
energy still goes to supply-side options
of that dollar that goes to demand side
options 80 cent still goes to technology
better light switches better lights
better appliances smart grid etc only
twenty cents
out of that ten dollars is going to
study things like behavior and attitudes
and values so I think this means two
things the first is we need more energy
are indeed if you look here at how the
US federal government is from Daniel
caman at Berkeley has spent its research
money energy is just here I mean look
how it compares to defense or space or
on this other area so it should probably
increase at least double if it's true
that energy and climate are such a key
problem and the second thing is we have
to fundamentally change its scope to not
just be technology we need
anthropologists sociologists
psychologists and others telling us how
we can cause the transition that we need
to have right and so I would say at
least half let's say that half the
problem is technology and half is
society and social things why not put
half the money into studying those
things it also be good for us social
scientists in the room but I think it
more accurately reflects the types of
barriers that remain when we talk about
clean power I've always been told it's
good to have data sources so everything
in this presentation comes
these four articles that are cited here
or these two books email me I'd be happy
to show you the articles the books at
least are really really cheap on Amazon
for like a dollar or something
thank you former students so and I'm
happy to share chapters of them as well
and if any of you would like to contact
me to get the slides or ask questions
here in my details and thank you for
your time